si la nouvelle gratuité du vaccin contre
la grippe pour tous n'a pas déplacé les
foules dans les centres de vaccination
cela en a tout de même décidé certains à
se déplacer j'avais jamais pris le
vaccin pour la grippe je pense a été
jamais recommandé pour ma tranche d'âge
mais c'était vraiment juste pour pas
passer Nelson cette année absolument on
l'aurait pas fait sinon oui ça fait de
la différence c'est excellent
pour certains la perspective d'une
population plus largement vaccinée les
ratures
d'autres restent réticents oui pour le
vaccin contre la covid 19 mais celui
contre la grippe attendra
c'est plus l'impression qu'il est
possible efficace la saison est pourtant
déjà bien avancée en date du 19 novembre
près de 900 cas de grippe ont été
déclarés au Québec avec un taux de
positivité de plus de 13%. on est trois
quatre semaines en avance par rapport
aux saisons habituelles et on est à des
niveaux qui sont d'habitude ce quand les
vacances de Noël et les regroupements
familiaux se sont déjà commencé les
personnes de 60 ans et plus sont les
plus touchés ainsi que les adolescents
de moins de 19 ans les enfants de moins
de 4 ans étant les plus hospitalisés
entre la covid-19 le virus respiratoire
s'incitial et une grippe dont la souche
dominante et virulente pour certains pas
question de courir le risque car nos
faits ont eu un an et ont eu
bronchiolite hospitalisation donc on
veut pas que ça arrive encore des
experts auraient aimé que la gratuité
souhaitait élargie à tous plus
rapidement mais il n'est pas trop tard
pour le temps des fêtes il y a pas trop
tard habituellement quand on reçoit une
vaccination les anticorps se développent
dans au cours des deux semaines
subséquentes donc on a vraiment le temps
de se protéger pour la saison des fêtes
selon elle c'est justement le moment
idéal pour aller chercher sa dose pour
tout l'hiver ici Camille Faye zen
Radio-Canada Montréal